race if soloquister abracadabra
caveat mtor avada kedara
why do lawyers use such funny words it
actually
has nothing to do with lawyers inventing
highfalutin legal words in order to
sound smart wear that already and as a
graduate of both law school and hogwarts
i can tell you that lawyers don't have
magic words but over time all
professions build up a special
vocabulary to help describe things in
very specific language and usually
it's not magic but sometimes it is sort
of magic and when mark jaffe posted on
twitter what genuine law term
sounds fake you have to convince people
you didn't make it up i knew i had to
share some of the most ridiculous legal
terms out there
and if i have to deal with these legal
terms every day i'm taking you legal
eagles with me
[Music]
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
alright so the first ridiculous legal
term that we have to deal with
is pendente lite now you might think
this is a mexican locale beer pendente
lite
tastes the lawyer or maybe it's a fancy
pendant light
or perhaps it is the lowest weight class
in boxing pendente lite one step below
the 108 pound flyweight but what it
actually
is has nothing to do with youtubers
turning into boxers pendente lite is a
latin term meaning awaiting the
litigation or
pending the litigation you often see
this during divorce and custody
litigation a court can issue a temporary
order of support pendante litee to
maintain the financial status quo of all
parties of the divorce while
it's pending and court orders are often
used to provide relief until the final
judgment is rented and the adverbial
form of this
would be a list pendants but that's also
its own special legal document usually
regarding real estate oh god this is
already getting incredibly complicated
but on to the second ridiculous term
which is
champerty now you might think that
champerty is a character from the tv
show bridgeton
announcing lady champerty of the north
hampstead sherford upon tim's champions
might be a fraternity drinking game it
might be something people on hgtv's
house hunters would complain about
not having in their home like the
champerty water fountain for their dogs
but what it actually is is when a third
party
funds litigation now historically this
was known as maintenance and champerty
back in the middle ages noble started
funding frivolous lawsuits to buttress
the claims and
take a share of any profits for
themselves and black's law dictionary
defines this as
a champertis agreement as a bargain
between a stranger and a party to a
lawsuit by which the stranger pursues
the party's claims in consideration for
receiving part of any judgment of the
proceeds and perhaps the most
interesting thing is that these days
these kind of agreements are generally
not illegal
there's a whole world of litigation
finance out there that in the olden days
would have been considered champerty and
illegal for example now a hedge fund
could invest in litigation that the
plaintiffs couldn't afford to fund on
their own it actually allows
more people to access the justice system
than otherwise would be able to do
because of
the funds that they or their lawyers do
or don't possess but on the other hand
the funding party could be
a billionaire who has a grudge against
someone else as we saw with the
peter thiel lawsuits through hulk hogan
against gawker so idiot
double-edged sword but that takes us to
the next ridiculous legal term
which is mutatus motondis which could be
the high valyrian
for all lawyers must die it could be an
outtake from the lion king giving timon
and pumbaa a follow-up to hakuna matata
what a wonderful phrase or it could be
the title given to the most important
praying mantis in the world
well actually it's a latin phrase that
means when things change that should be
changed or
having changed what needs to be changed
it pops up a lot in legal circles when
lawyers are drafting contracts the
simplest explanation is for use in the
law and that
the necessary changes in details such as
names and places will be made but
everything else will remain the same
that explanation comes from the famous
judge shinelan
no not that judge shineland judge shira
shinelan who is well known to all
lawyers for her groundbreaking decisions
in electronic discovery which still form
the backbone of federal rules that
govern electronic information
in litigation which takes us to the next
ridiculous legal term
the suggestion of death now is the
suggestion of death a proper way of
insulting opposing counsel
i move to strike opposing counsel upon
suggestion
of death is it a spell or event from
dungeons and dragons
is it what happens in the organ trail
when you unsuccessfully try to forward a
river
or is it a charles bronson movie
suggestion of death
from the producers of death wish and
chasing amy well actually according to
henry campbell black the man who
literally wrote the book
on legal terms he explains that a
suggestion of death
is a quote statement formally entered on
the record of some fact or circumstance
which will materially affect
further proceedings in the cause i know
it looks weird since a person's death is
usually not a suggestion
it's a fact but a suggestion of death
functions as a legal announcement of
death and
fyi to inform the court and opposing
parties that a key person has died a
case doesn't necessarily go away just
because someone dies although that can
happen
but this is just a lawyer's way of
letting everyone know that something
kind of major has happened
in the case which takes us to the next
ridiculous legal term
an attractive nuisance is an attractive
nuisance the person you run into a bar
at last call
you feeling what i'm feeling if it's
resignation
then yes is it the song that you can't
get out of your head
is it free cake in the office break room
when you're on a diet is it when your
pets or children
are annoying you while you're trying to
work from home especially
when you're on a zoom call um pardon me
well actually an attractive nuisance is
something that's on
your property that is attractive and
exciting to children property owners
have a special duty of care to children
and teens
because they can't fully understand the
dangers posed by certain situations this
means that if you have a bucket of candy
or a ps5
sitting on a float in your swimming pool
you might expect the children
are going to trespass onto your property
and while often you're not
obligated to protect trespassers
sometimes you have to look out for those
stupid attractive nuisance children in
other words you're obligated to mitigate
the danger by taking steps to prevent
them from accessing the property put up
a fence cover the pool
and keep your video games downstairs in
your mom's basement
which takes us to the next ridiculous
legal term a heart balm
tort now a heartbalm tort could be an
assignment on the great british baking
show probably something
really dumb like a whole peach wrapped
in a thousand layers of
pastry and then baked for some
ridiculous amount of time like
12 hours could be blank love the flavor
it's a charming cake a little bit of a
mess
thank you so much it could be a magic
spell
i command a level 5 heart bomb tort
against you
or it could be a hallmark movie about a
down and out heart surgeon michael baum
who
leaves his big city practice to start up
a bakery and falls in love with a woman
who can't stop eating his mini pies
but actually a heart balm tort is a
specific kind of civil suit
often referred to as a torch that is
brought against someone who has
interfered in a relationship or made a
promise that they didn't keep this lets
people sue their spouses paramore or
bring charges against men who
promised to marry someone but then
backed out these suits flourished in the
early 20th century when newspapers
featured lurid tales of gold-digging
harlots who
broke up marriages and then preyed on
widowers eventually there were so many
heart bomb tort cases
that they were actually abolished in
more than 40 states but that takes us to
the next ridiculous legal term
a frolic and detour now is a frolic and
detour a
pair of animated mischievous kittens as
in tom and jerry itchy and scratchy
is it the new michael chabon novel or is
it the newest kardashian baby name
frolic and detour along with rumor scout
apple northwest
and elon musk's formula well actually
it's a term that covers the little side
trip that an employee takes when they're
supposed to be on duty and of course
when accidents happen who's responsible
when an employee does something that's
on their own
but on company time well generally
employers are liable for any damages
caused by their employees but if someone
is acting way outside the scope of their
job
the employer might be able to show that
the employee should be held legally
responsible a
frolic is when an employee totally
departs from his or her duties let's say
your boss sends you to office max for
supplies but
on the way there you stop off at a
casino to play some slot machines for an
hour and on the way back you get into a
traffic accident the trip to the casino
is completely unrelated to your job
duties so the employer won't be legally
responsible on the other hand
a mere detour is just more of a minor
deviation that probably doesn't absolve
your employer of
liability for example if you go to
officemax in our example and then stop
at starbucks on your way back
and then get into a traffic accident in
this instance you've probably only made
a slight deviation from your job duties
so the accident may be within the scope
of your job and your employer
might have to pay for the damages but
that takes us to the next ridiculous
legal term
quiet enjoyment now is quiet enjoyment
the nap time at a montessori school
after you have already played a game of
heads up 7up is it something your
parents desperately want especially
during kovid or is it a
cover band for quiet riot well actually
quiet enjoyment comes up in the
real estate context it's usually a
covenant of quiet enjoyment and is one
of the promises the property owner or
tenant gets as part of his or her right
to possess
and use the property this means that the
person has the right to enjoy the
property without
interference this covers things like a
landlord repeatedly harassing a tenant
or
vermin inside the walls making noises at
all hours of the day and night if you
are renting property
you have the right to quiet enjoyment
and that might mean you're able to
listen to
quite riot but that takes us to the next
ridiculous legal term this one is one of
my favorites a
fertile octogenarian now is a fertile
octogenarian
mick jagger larry king a rejected
pokemon or the title of tlc's newest
hit reality show i'm marrying a fertile
octogenarian well a fertile oxygenarian
may actually refer to
all of those things but in a legal
context it means something very specific
this usually involves property law and
is the source of
many headaches for law students because
a fertile octogenarian is a fictitious
character that we make up in property
law to demonstrate the concept against
the rule against perpetuities and while
it often takes a long time to wrap your
head around it is actually kind of a
simple concept that is
meant to make sure that there is
certainty about who gets what
if you're going to give property to a
certain category of people
you have to know that all of those
people are certain within 21 years
of the death of the person who is living
so for example
if you said i give all of my property to
aunt bertha
who is 100 years old and all of aunt
bertha's
children well the thing is even though
aunt bertha is a hundred years old
the law presumes that she could have
more children so that bequest doesn't
work because it violates the rule
against perpetuities because we assume
that even if you're an octogenarian the
law thinks that you still could be
fertile look i don't know the law is
weird
what do you want from me but that takes
us to the next ridiculous legal term
an unborn widow now is an unborn widow
an
amish romance novel is it a sad bon iver
song which
is there any other kind or is it a
christian horror movie about a ghost
that was never born because the couple
used
contraceptives instead well actually an
unborn widow is actually related to
the last fertile octogenarian yes
property law is the gift that keeps on
giving now let's say you had a
complicated will and you wanted to leave
a house to let's say
gary for his life and then to gary's
widow for her life
and then to gary's children after they
pass away now the property can't be
given to
gary's widow until gary is dead which is
totally fine from a legal perspective
but property law asks us to assume the
most ridiculous far out thing imaginable
like
what happens if gary marries a woman who
isn't even born at the time that you
made the gift to gary what if gary
is actually mick jagger and you left him
a house back in 1980 but mick jagger
later marries a woman
born in 1999. but here's the problem he
could die and then his new bride could
outlive him for way longer than 21 years
and the rule against perpetuity says
that the interest must vest
within 21 years so that transfer would
be invalid from the outset because
of the possibility of the unborn widow
but frankly i think my movie idea is a
way better one anyway but that takes us
to the next
ridiculous legal term a precocious
toddler
now is a precocious toddler a hit
podcast for moms who know that their
toddlers are gifted
is the name of gwyneth paltrow's baby
store is it a never made adam sandler
movie starring kevin james
as adam sandler's son i mean who
wouldn't want to see that i'm just full
of great movie ideas but in reality a
precocious toddler goes back to property
law once more and our favorite rule
against perpetuities because we've
already talked about how the law
requires you to believe
completely insane things like an
octogenarian
being a fertile or the ability for
anyone to marry someone who isn't even
born yet and if you have to assume those
things you better believe
the law requires you to think that
everyone
is fertile at birth i went to law school
for this
frankly this is all just jiggery pokery
which is our next ridiculous legal word
now
is jiggery pokery a phrase that will get
you fired from work because it's racist
is it an old-timey card game that is
racist is it a very outdated disney park
ride that seems
just a little bit racist or is it a
beloved vintage children's book that
might be racist well actually children
this racist sounding phrase isn't racist
at all it's just some bizarre slang from
england that justice antonin scalia
picked up but it's a bit of a punt
because it literally means
legal nonsense the earliest known use of
this phrase was actually in 1845 by the
berkshire chronicle in reading england
the article was called protection to
agriculture and it commented that
under the present law the averages were
made up so faithfully and fairly as to
prevent any jiggery pokery and justice
scalia deployed the phrase jiggery
pokery
to attack chief justice roberts for the
court 6-3 decision that it was legal for
the irs to extend tax credits for the
affordable care act to federal exchanges
as well as those created by the states
so that takes us to our
next terms flummery tommy rot balderdash
and poppycock now no those aren't
technically legal words but they do
describe people who don't check out the
extended version of this video over
on nebula is dicta the head coach of
de bears or is it the source of one's
manhood in fact almost all of my videos
have an ad-free extended version on
nebula and now you can get a huge
discount
because sometimes talking about jiggery
pokery is too hot for youtube
which is why my creator friends and i
teamed up to build our own platform
where creators don't need to worry about
demonetization
or the dreaded algorithm it's called
nebula and we're thrilled to be
partnering with curiositystream because
nebula is a place where creators can do
what they do best
create and it's a place where we can
both house our content ad-free
and also experiment with original
content and new series that probably
wouldn't work
on youtube so not only are my nebula
versions ad free and extended but
they're also released early before the
youtube version and nebula features lots
of youtube's top educational-ish
creators like lindsay ellis
h bomberguy and medlife crisis and we
get to collaborate in ways that probably
wouldn't work on youtube and put out
amazing original content like half as
interesting as courtroom drama where i
play a real life
fake lawyer now what does this have to
do with curiosity stream well
as the go-to source for the best
documentaries on the platform like peter
sagel's history
they love educational creators and we
worked out a deal where if you sign up
for curiosity stream with the link in
the description
you'll also get a nebulous subscription
for free and to be clear
that nebulous subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member and right now
curiosity stream is offering 26
off of their annual plans that's less
than 15 a year for both curiosity stream
and nebula together so if you click on
the link in the description you'll get
both curiosity stream and nebula for 26
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legal eagle it's a great way to support
this channel
and educational content directly for
under 15
per year so just click on the link in
the description plus clicking on that
link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis about all these
crazy legal terms leave your objections
in the comments and check out this
playlist over here with all my other
videos about
crazy laws and legal misunderstandings
so click on this playlist
or i'll see you in court